we do have a question so if you all want
to pop your questions and we do have one
question from Joanne asking if there
could be some clarification around Kobe
two stars Kobe two's requirement for
reverse currents transcription in the
central dogma so I don't know if you
want to just sort of like clarify that
aspect so so there's well if we went
back to the screen should I go back you
can go for it okay so so when it goes
from this RNA molecule to this messenger
RNA
it uses a what we call is a polymerase
or this is just a fancy word for saying
a protein that copies this to another
molecule so it uses it's a polymerase
that makes RNA based off of RNA so
obviously that's not the way DNA is
transferred to tamari so for the virus
it's not really a reverse situation but
it's the kind of molecules that are
cells used to make reverse transcription
I guess made any sense I think I think
like it's it's it's always like tricky
because when we we're so used to
learning everything in these like DNA
based systems right and so remembering
that there in RNA and they have to go
backwards and then forwards and like all
of these things they're also replicating
each other and like it's all there's a
lot of biology going on in this case
it's just going forward yeah and I think
this there's also the difficulty since
the way that we're doing the testing for
us to be able to work with that you need
to be able to make DNA and that's where
the reverse transcriptase comes in for
us so we have a question from Katherine
sultani who asks if the genome sequence
can be studied now for kovin 19 or i
guess the new corona virus can that help
us with predicting future corona viruses
it it may and so there's even you know a
lot of the research that has been done
to study the receptor binding domain has
come from research from studying the
original corona virus so it's not just
all this research just happened but it's
actually many years of understanding the
structure of the the genome and so
if this also mutates further it could
also help us understand if if the
current growing virus changes in ways
that are important
great thanks and that was my cousin
hello Katie hope you're well okay so we
have a question from Facebook from Peggy
do you know if there have been mutations
observed since the outbreak began in
humans so there have been some mutations
but those mutations well so in general
mutations can occur and viruses can
occur mutations for example more faster
than then we can and so there there can
be lots of different mutations and again
it's also about if all the DNA are all
the genes or genomes of the viruses are
being sequenced properly but there's two
mutations that have occurred in in that
have kind of been passed along and that
have allowed people to really track
different populations but whether those
mutations are affecting people in
different ways that hasn't really been
answered ok so a question from Lauren
freed which is how do scientists know to
look for the virus in bats and pangolins
is there a reason behind why bats carry
so many corona viruses I think so one of
the things to think about is that
viruses are just all around us so it's
one of the most abundant types of
genetic material and like living being
or almost living being that there is so
there's even viruses that infect viruses
and we may have other kinds of viruses
that aren't infecting us so much but
it's just I guess known from prior
studies that that bats host a lot of
these corona viruses probably after the
initial outbreaks it was a race to find
but but also that's part of this
collecting different materials from
different animals I'm some some people
even during times when there's not an
outbreak they're just collecting lots of
viruses from different animals the
Pangolin actually had symptoms that are
that were very like what corona virus is
now and so it was probably just a
standard procedure that they kept the
tissues and the cells of the Pangolin
and i'm not sure if they sequenced the
the gene right away but maybe they once
they saw the you know similarities then
they may have
yeah thanks and I think also I know that
there are bad people who are very
specifically studying coronaviruses in
bats oh they're more like that
ecologists and then there's virology
people who are studying coronaviruses
who are now also or who have been for
many years talking about bats as a
reservoir for other things so it's a
it's a this is not something that I just
wanted to also add that that is not
something that is new everybody has in
the scientific communities have known
that coronaviruses are these things that
are existing in bats for a really long
time and so there is quite a bit of
literature on corona viruses and bats
all over the place so I'm gonna ask a
facebook question another Facebook
question from Carolina and the question
is around how we can easily explain to
others what a lab signature is maybe in
a simple way and just following up on
that how easy would it be to create a
virus like this in the lab and I also
want to preface this question with just
saying viruses have been around for
billions of years humans have not I you
know so they're incredibly sophisticated
so I'll just throw it at you now yeah so
what I mean by lab signature is they're
usually specific genes that people use
that make things resistant to different
drugs or allow us to see them under a
microscope and they like for example
turn green and so those allow us to
really look at things or or like
otherwise just just kind of enrich for
them to make them actually study about
otherwise they'll be kind of mixed up
with all the other viruses and so I
don't know if that clarified or if we
call them like little selection tags you
know in the lab so I don't know if
that's it just helps to make sure they
remain concentrated
yeah being able to stick a label on
something and then be able to pick it
out at a later date yeah yeah so like
for example now this coronavirus the new
coronavirus has been taken and put in
into those kinds of sequences so that
people can study them and really figure
out how they work and so that we can
create drugs and stuff like that so it's
it's not an impossible thing to do but
we would expect that if this virus was
out there infecting people that we would
be able to see that signature from the
sequences of patients that had bars and
do you think it's easy to create a
something like this in a lab well the
thing is yeah we don't really know like
nature has a lot of opportunities and
and we have a lot less kind of foresight
to to know actually what's going to
create B all the things that can create
very very deadly virus currently we know
now that this virus is very deadly
that's only in retro in hindsight yeah
so I feel like I Betty and I are
becoming firm friends I always ask her
questions so she has a two-parter and
this is is there a specific mechanism
for pangolins or bats to transmit the
virus to humans and how would this be
different from human to human
transmission well I don't think there's
a specific you know anything different
than humans transferring it from it's
just the way that people interact with
these animals so for example the
Pangolin that was found these don't
naturally live in China they're found in
different areas of the world and this
was their usually trafficked animals and
so you know
not having that interaction with that
Pinkle and would have helped if it
wasn't trafficked the bats obviously are
not or I don't know if they're how
people are interacting with beds but
it's just you know if you're how you
behave or interact with things in close
proximity right so this is a really
great question from Tiffany and that is
around the implication that Tsarskoe b2
is 96% related to the bat sequences that
were examined here yet
the receptor binding domain is more
similar to the Pangolin um you know what
what does that mean so I guess no one
possibility is that so the way I showed
how the genes of the virus get
transmitted it happens like in this very
stepwise fashion it's like one mutation
next mutation but also sometimes the
strains of different viruses can mix
together so different regions and
mutations can then transfer so it could
be possible that a corona virus like the
one that's is seen in the event also
mixed with the the one that's found in
the Pangolin and another possibility is
that there was already one like the one
that we saw now but it just wasn't
sequenced
so we have a quick question from Johanna
which is if this virus present in
Pangolin saliva
I'm not I'm not sure yeah I was thinking
just in case this was something that was
mentioned in the course of writing this
paper like how they were the animals
were sampled for the to be up to detect
the virus right you know I think they
just took the tissues from actually it
was two dead penguins and they they had
died from coronavirus like symptoms and
and so yeah I don't know how they they
took so I I think there is a question
that is asking around like maybe are
there other animals that could have also
contributed to this whole thing and so
like why did the scientists focus only
on the bats and the Penguins were there
other things or maybe are there other
things that are not even in our range of
thought or understanding so the reason
why they focus on it is because they
they found similarity from those
sequences that were in that catalog and
so the way this worked is actually they
didn't even sequence the whole genome of
the viruses so they just sequenced a
specific region a specific protein that
the virus has and they first assessed
like how similar in that region and then
they actually have to do a lot of
sequencing so it's actually quite a lot
of work because they can't it's very
difficult to sequence the whole genome
and so there are probably different
animals out there with with very you
know with coronavirus like symptoms but
but these are the ones that were in the
catalog so for example oh I think we
know that cats can also they also have
an ace 2 receptor that is very similar
to humans and that allows for the new
carniverous to bind to that and I'm sure
there are other animals camels were
initially affected and pre
coronavirus outbreaks
okay so from ADP again is the rate of
mutations and pangolins and bat
coronavirus is parallel to that of
humans so the rate of the coronavirus
should depend on the actual coronavirus
and it actually has some proofreading
when it's using its replicating it has a
proofreading way to the correct itself
so it it's a rate of mutation is lower
than other viruses that usually don't
have that proofreading ability but I
don't I wouldn't imagine it depending on
the host but
so we have a great question around from
Aneesa around east to and so like what
is it normally are you know if you if
you're aware of what a stew normally
does in our bodies and then you know
maybe like why a stew why would the
coronavirus use that as the receptor if
if you even know I don't even know if we
know that answer
yeah so I don't know what a stew is
doing on the cell so I know that it's a
receptor and that it's expressed on the
sales of lungs but other other tissues
as well but I don't think it's the kind
of it's not like looking to take
advantage of the h2 receptor it's that
the a is two receptor has you know some
structure that allows it to kind of
enter cells and infect cells and
continue being able to have its life
cycle so if if it can't infect cells
through interacting with the ACE to
receptor then it has to find a different
way to keep living
so I had one question before we tap out
I guess and this is more regarding where
the information for the paper came from
so given that this is a review and the
people presenting the information didn't
do the experiments how did the authors
choose the papers that they then
subsequently described so the the way
authors usually do this is that they
review the articles within the field and
they think they they use which is most
relevant to the kind of case that
they're trying to make and they also
read the papers very thoroughly and and
try to establish which one is more
credible but yeah it's it's it's mostly
them looking and actually developing
this knowledge over a long period of
time of knowing which what is the
research out there what does everybody
saying so we have kind of different ways
of sharing information from different
meetings or just reading articles and so
that's and that's also why seven
different people wrote this publication
so people have different expertise --is
that may overlap but there's going to be
things that some people are more expert
in so we have a bunch of scientists
right now on the panel and I'd like to
maybe open it up to everybody if anybody
wants to join in but I was just
wondering like what your what are your
thoughts on the pace of research and how
we've been sharing this information like
our I mean what I just I personally feel
that I've never seen science move so
fast in my life I feel like we're in
like this like Ferris Bueller situation
that if we don't stop and look around
you know everything will pass us by and
I don't know maybe Ferris Bueller is a
bit of a tell for my generation I don't
you know who Tharus dealer is out there
but you know and do you think that this
will change the way we think about doing
science in the future how we think about
collaboration and things like that I
don't know is anybody else want to join
or does anybody have any thoughts on
that or you can you can start us off if
you want Andris well I think science is
quite a collaborative endeavor already
you know there are some competition I
mean there's quite a lot of big a lot of
competition but there's also you know
this willingness to share as well that's
increased a lot so there's a lot of
people doing things and sharing
everything more openly and trying to
kind of solve this problem
together but you know if it's not
related to the pandemic I'm not sure if
that kind of feeling is gonna continue
or right so at some point I was working
in a lab doing Alzheimer's research and
it feels like for a very long time this
has already been something that as you
say has been going at breakneck speed
and I think that's partly due to the
scientific structure the fact that
scientists are expected to publish so
many papers that for Alzheimer's there
is just no earthly way you could read
every relevant paper that came out on a
given day so it would be interesting to
see how this moves forward because I
think that potentially we don't need
more information we just needed to be
more succinct and easier to translate
and I know some people are going through
journal articles and they're trying to
compile you know the most relevant bits
of information from certain papers and I
don't know how you do that without
losing any of the information
yeah I wonder if the course of Kovac 19
everything that's coming out as a result
of it will will help us home the amount
of information coming out yeah I think
yeah I think I love I I think your point
on dress also on like will this apply to
non-covered stuff I don't know that's a
really fair point
and so thanks for sharing that